how often would guys take shots in their
body armor or helmet
all the time this happened all the time
and uh when we were
in that urban combat in all
sustained combat day after day after day
both for for us and charlie platoon
and in our sister platoon delta platoon
that was operating on the other side of
the city
it was just did this happen regularly i
mean we had guys
uh you know on patrol with a camelback
you know and
you know the camelbak's got is a water
bladder on the back you wear the
backpack it's got the little hose tube
that you can
you can drink water on on the move guys
no no water is backpack realize
later round went through it i mean
you're talking inches away you know from
his back
we had multiple guys shot in the plates
uh front plate
back plate um and got one one of our
guys
peeking up over the rooftop during a big
gunfight bam takes takes uh
all of a sudden he felt like somebody
punched him in the face and uh kind of
falls back down below the roof
and kind of gets up wondering what's
happening and takes off his helmet looks
his helmet realizes he's been shot in
his night vision mount
uh which meant that that round came in
directly you know
at his face hit his hit his night vision
mounted ricocheted up
had it hit just you know millimeters
lower it would have
taken his head off so that happened all
the time and and i
i i'm sure jocko you remember this many
times i would we would
come back from up park our homies i'd
walk in the door i was gonna check him
with jocko let him know you know
what what what happened out there what's
going on you know what's what's
happening
you know uh now you know are there other
ops we need to get reloaded for things
to think about
walking in his office and first thing i
would generally say was
god is a frog man god's a frog man he's
looking out for us i don't know how we
made it out of that without losing guys
or you know this was
so many close calls uh and it was just a
constant thing
all the time wear your body armor
wear your helmet yeah we we always had
guys on our and you've talked about this
in the podcast before but
my first appointment we would have guys
that would wear body armor that was like
like six inches by six minimalistic
bodies tiny little body armor nobody
uh you know and and in ramadi getting
those kind of gunfights
everyone was like hey can we get a
little bigger place
some guys wanted to cut their helmets
into half shells before we got there
after we got there it was like
no no i'm not cutting my own yeah some
of the artists get a little more
some of the army guys they would have
the full they look like almost like
knights the crotch protector the cross
protector the collars the arm sleeves
the side sappy plates they they were
covered up good on them
because they were uh you know taking
real risks out there so yeah but
you know jody medic and i when he was on
here we had a little conversation about
body armor they didn't open
expected to be in a certain spot they
weren't there they didn't have body
armor helmets on and he you know he's
sitting here saying i wish that would
have had him
so wear your body armor wear your helmet
all the time